one of the things that I figured out
over the last years is this is a good
proposition so you know it's pretty
self-evident that life is have got its
rat's nest of miseries and that's for
sure maybe you could even make a
categorical statement that life is
mostly a rat's nest of misery you know
you could make a pretty powerful
argument for that but then there's a
counter question which is well what if
you tried not to make it any more
miserable that had had to be right then
what then what would it be like and my
suspicions are is that a lot of that
misery I would suspect that most of that
misery would go away because it's the
unnecessary misery that really brings
you down you know it's like well someone
has cancer it's like that sucks but it's
not like it's not like you can say if
only we had done this differently then
that wouldn't have happened but when
someone's out like car Turing you in a
malevolent way or maybe you're doing the
same you can always ask yourself was
really this really necessary is this
just like I'm useless add on to the
miseries of life that's what disheartens
people and so even in your own life if
if you if you aren't suffering from
self-imposed misery and you're only
suffering from inescapable misery maybe
you could handle that and you know you
could you could survive you could bear
it and even maybe without becoming
irredeemably corrupt so the goal would
be well yeah life is a rat's nest of
miseries and maybe it has no ultimate
meaning we could say that we're feeling
particularly pessimistic but it still
leaves one question open which is you
didn't do everything you could to make
it worse how good could you make it be
and the least answer is well it could be
tragedy but maybe not hell and I think
that's right I really believe that
that's that's the most pessimistic
proper statement the worst-case outcome
in the worst of all possible worlds is
that your life could be tragic but not
hell and that's a lot better than hell
right it's it's you think I could give
you an example of the difference you're
at your mother's deathbed
well that's tragedy here's another
scenario you're at your mother's
deathbed and all you you and all your
idiot siblings are arguing well that's
the difference between tragedy and hell
and you might be able to tolerate the
first circumstance in
maybe it would even bring you closer
together with your family members the
second one no one can bear that you walk
away from a situation like that sick of
yourself and sick of everything else too
and you know it's often the case that
tragic circumstances bring out the
Dragons because the stress is high and
all those things that people haven't
dealt with they don't have the energy to
repress and and all the bitterness comes
pouring forward it's like seriously man
you know so that's actually a good
it's a rough lesson but it's a good
hallmark for figuring out whether or not
you're you've got yourself adjusted
properly and in relationship to your
siblings it's like if you are all
gathered around the bed of someone close
who is dying could you manage it if the
answer is no looks like well put your
life together
because it's going to happen and you
should be the person who's there that
can do it and do it properly and then
maybe you'd find that it isn't the sort
of thing that will undermine your faith
in life itself and I've seen I've seen
both of those situations you know ugly
ugly ugly situations you know
murderously ugly situations and then
they're opposite where people have had
terrible things happening to happen to
them as a family and you know they pull
together and they rebuild their damn
ship and they sail away so that seems to
me to be a lot better that makes you
know when the flood comes right well
okay so the same thing the question
emerges well who are you well you could
say your this plan that's what people
usually that's how people usually
identify maybe they have no plan at all
and they're just in chaos right that's
like being in the belly of the beast
nihilistic and chaos they have no plan
they're just chaos itself and that's a
very dreadful situation for people to be
in or maybe they conjure together a plan
that's their identity it's kind of
fragile and they're holding on to that
with with everything they've got it's
the little stick of wood that they're
floating in the ocean clinging to you
know and so they're identifying really
hard with that plan that's what happens
when you're Nydia log is that you're
identifying really hard with that plan
the problem is if something comes up to
confront it well how do you act well you
can't let go to the plan because you
drowned
you cling to it rigidly well that's no
good because then you can't learn
anything then if that's you you're a
totalitarian you're not going to learn
anything you're going to end up in
something that's close enough to hell so
that you won't know the difference and
you might drag everyone along with you
that's happen plenty of times right it's
the whole story the 20th century haven't
over and over and over and it happens in
people's states it happens in their
business organizations it happens in
their cities it happens in their
provinces it happens in their States and
it happens in their psyches all at the
same time you can't blame the
manifestation of that sort of thing on
any of those one levels it happens when
a society goes down that way it goes
down everywhere at the same time it's
not the totalitarians at the top and all
the happy people striving to be free at
the bottom it's not that at all it's
totalitarianism at every single level of
the hierarchy including the
psychological and so you don't want to
be the thing you don't want to be in
chaos that's for sure but you don't want
to be the thing that clings so
desperately to the raft that you can't
let go when someone comes to rescue you
right you don't want to be that so then
you think well exactly what are you you
know what the chaos you not the plan
maybe you're the thing that confronts
the obstacle and I would say that's the
categorical lesson of of psychology
insofar as it has to do with personal
transformation that's what you always
teach people in psychotherapy I don't
care what sort of psychotherapists you
are you're always teaching them the same
thing you're the thing that can you not
you're not
the plan you're the thing that can
confront the obstacle to the plant and
then when you know even further that the
obstacle is not only an obstacle but
opportunity itself well then your whole
view of the world can change because you
might think well I got this plan
something came up to object to it it's
like it's possible that the thing that's
objecting has something to teach you
that will take you to the place where
you develop an even better plan it's a
nice framework to use it's like are you
so sure that this is a problem is that
the only way that you can look at it or
is it an opportunity I mean I'm not
trying to be you know naively optimistic
there are some things that's pretty hard
to extract gold from some dragons and
maybe the death of a family member is a
good example of that but any even in the
situation like that I can tell you that
it's an opportunity for
it's an opportunity for maturation
that's for sure and the thing is you
might say well it's pretty miserable to
go to be digging for gold when someone's
falling into the grave well if they
really love you first of all that's what
they'll want you to do and second you're
going to make their death a lot more
palatable experience for them if you're
someone who can be in the room and be
helpful instead of be you know quivering
in the corner and feeling that the
entire world is collapsing in on you and
that's another you want to be the useful
person at the funeral how's that for a
goal that's a good goal man you know
that you've got yourself together in a
situation like that because you're going
to be at them and maybe you want to be
the person on whose shoulder people cry
that'd be a good goal that's kind of you
know I don't like being naively
optimistic so when I tell you to get
your life together I'm not going to say
roses and sunshine it's like that's
that's that's that's pablum for fools
but it really is something to be the
reliable person at a funeral right and
you can aim at that you can do that it's
you've got to be tough to do that
because it also means that you can
sustain a major loss without collapsing
that you've got to be a monster to do
that right